today we're talking about how popular
elden ring is how game pass could be
coming to steam and more
the list of best-selling games on steam
for the past week has been revealed and
unsurprisingly from software's massively
anticipated eldon ring has topped the
charts eldering claimed the top three
spots on steam for the week ending in
february 27th and it was able to hold
more than one position because like many
other games it has multiple purchasing
options steam's own back end lists them
as separate games and this data is
pulled and compiled by steamdb coming in
at fourth for the eighth week of 2022
was destiny 2 the witch queens deluxe
edition with the standard version
landing in the sixth spot for the week
steam's own steam deck console was
number 7 while dying light 2 total war
warhammer 3 and cyberpunk 2077 also made
it to the top sales spots
and in other steam news can you imagine
a world in which game pass was available
through steam while valve boss gabe
newell has commented on the possibility
and said there's a chance speaking to pc
gamer newell said that valve is unlikely
to create a similar service of its own
but working with microsoft to add game
pass to steam might be something that
valve would consider valve has a history
of supporting subscription programs on
steam with ea's own ea play offering
arriving on steam back in 2020. game
pass is microsoft's subscription-based
offering that gets subscribers access to
a growing catalog of games for one price
and personally i have a huge grudge
against the game pass pc app it only
works when it wants to and i've run into
issues opening the app installing games
launching games etc so using steam to
manage my game pass games instead would
be amazing
switching gears to the 9th gen of pocket
monsters the pokemon company has
announced the next gen of pokemon games
scarlet and violet and both are coming
to the nintendo switch later this year
the games were revealed via a teaser
trailer at the end of the pokemon day
pokemon presents live stream giving
glimpses into the world players will be
hunting pokemon in as well as a quick
peek at the three starters from this
unnamed region the official announcement
notes that this new region has various
towns without borders that blend into
the wilderness so you may not have hard
cuts in between town transitions it also
says you'll be able to see pokemon
roaming around anywhere including inside
towns are you ready for another pokemon
adventure in 2022 how many hours have
you packed into eldon ring so far let me
know in the comments and we'll see you
again tomorrow
you